uh one of the questions referred to this
guy introduced a new function actually
interested new pair of functions um
believe it or not this is pronounced
cosh x
and i think from memory they define it
as being e to the x plus e to the minus
x on two does that sound about right
things like question 13 to 14 something
like that okay
our kosh x has a brother named believe
it or not
shine x i didn't make it up that's how
they pronounce it pronounce it
mathematicians whatever okay
now you're like
what like these
textbook authors they're just making
stuff up you know it's just no they're
not hear your calculator there
right there in the middle next to sign
in fact you'll see a button which says
hype
hype
any guesses what it stands for
it stands for hyperbolic now if your
calculator is on
and you up excuse me
excuse me if you press the high volume
button uh up appears a whole bunch of
functions two of which include cosh and
shine okay so
uh i'm going to explain very briefly
what these two are and show you what
they look like do you need to know them
no
i i met them at university level maths
uh where did i learn them they'd be
different
i can't remember honestly um
but you don't just learn stuff because
you have to that stuff is cool and these
guys are cool now here's the question
for you
i just have a look at what they are
they're built off exponential functions
okay
why are they called
what they are
weird names they have nothing to do with
trig
do they
now i would you have a thing about why
why might they have called them you know
caution shine they have pretty
ridiculous names so they obviously had
to have a good reason for them okay
uh let me ask this first
all of these functions have a kind of
symmetry right you guys know about
different kinds of symmetry there's two
main types
what kinds of surgery do you see for
kosh what kind of symmetry does it have
look at it think about it carefully
if you can't see it right away then
maybe you should do what i do
and uh graph people hate graphic don't
they but it's such a good diagnostic
tool such a good thinking deal okay
what does this guy look like uh
edx
we know what that looks like
what does e to the minus x look like in
comparison to that
same thing but it's been flipped
horizontally yeah so okay let's see how
i go something like
haha i got it
i'm not going to do that the next
hundred times oh well okay so there you
go that's what even minus x looks like
we're gonna add them up and then we're
going to halve them now immediately even
before i add them you can probably see
what kind of symmetry are you going to
expect
has a name
you're adding two things together which
are mirror images of each other across
the y-axis right so what kind of
symmetry will you get
um this is this is one isn't it uh y
equals one so you're gonna add the mask
you get two but then you're halving it
okay so you're actually going through
here what's happening over here on the
right hand side okay let's just actually
consider it without the two
you're gonna be here there's there's two
and one okay what happens as you
approach infinity
you're going to be approaching this
you're actually asymptotic to e to the x
right
you're never going to cross it though
why not
you're always adding something it is
getting smaller and smaller it's smaller
but it's never zero and it's never
negative okay so you're gonna approach
approach approach but never quite get
there okay
the same thing's happening on the other
side just in reverse okay so you're
getting this kind of shape
so now you take that and you
have it okay so i guess it'll be
something like this i don't know it's
roughly okay so there you go that thick
looking guy in the middle there
that's
kosh
what kind of symmetry does it have
it has even symmetry right
even symmetry what kind of symmetry does
cosine regular cosine have
that's interesting
also even symmetry right
i won't complete it for shine okay i'll
just draw an input your shine looks like
this
okay when you subtract instead of adding
okay now there's one other key
similarity
that uh
shine and kosh have to their
non-hyperbolic cousins right and it's
actually the subject of the question so
when you differentiate
shine
okay what do you get right you
differentiate e to the x minus e to the
e to the minus x of 2. so what happens
to the e to the x
you just get e to the x
what happens to this guy it's chain rule
the derivative inside function is minus
one okay so that comes out the front
and oh that's interesting
another similarity now there are more
than that i'll let you go and if you're
curious you can go and research high
voltage personal traffic sign but that's
what it's about i'm interested
what am i reading what am i even doing
okay this is what they're talking about